you ever wish your dreams would come
true well look no farther I'm here to
help you
[Music]
so I suppose tweet out I wish I was and
I will today me and I will today make
your dreams come true it's already kind
of [ __ ] amazing how all of you are
failing at this simple tweet instruction
that I gave you half of you are posting
a picture other half of just posting
pictures of memes alright we have Nina
here finally a fan who knows how to
follow simple instructions Nina yes I
will turn you into a shark stupid hair
sharks don't have hair at least help me
out a little bit here Nina Jesus Christ
have hair everywhere my god you want to
be a shark you could at least try a
little bit that's all I'm saying
now let's this match contrast we are
going places looks pretty legit
I forgot the shark fins god damn it so I
feel bad because I took away her hair
Who am I to strip a hair from a hair
girl okay
sharks have feelings too you know that's
that was the point that is the shark by
the magic of the PewDiePie I made you
into a shark before after before a your
wish is my macmaine to have to stay my
life
another satisfied customer
[Music]
here's someone saying I wish I was a
gremlin I'm guessing it's the baby who
tweeted me
the eyes are [ __ ] huge all right
let's get on that the hell is wrong with
this baby ha ha ha it's good good stuff
what else we got we got that weird ass
mouth all right
should be easy I think yeah did a pretty
good shot poor baby
I feel I feel like I shouldn't feel bad
but I really don't your wish is my
command you are now a gremlin you're
welcome
there's a cookie lady again she keeps
trying stop posting pics god damn it she
really look at many times she tweets
look oh my god
oh my god Who am I to not make her a
cookie I am just too nice that blends
pretty well stupid Instagram filter
making it hard for me though ok Jesus
Christ that's actually kind of
terrifying what the [ __ ]
Who am I to not let people be a cookie
remember remember kids
don't let people say what you can't do
if you want to be a cookie you can be a
goddamn cook if you want don't let
anyone stop you from following your
dreams of becoming a cookie you know we
gonna bake bake bake bake bake you know
we're gonna bake bake bake bake your
heart I never seen anyone in my life
wanting to be a cookie disband like it's
kind of [ __ ] amazing there you go
it's making all everyone's wish come
true today it's it's so good to be me
it looks so [ __ ] creepy hope you're
happy that's just scary
hey was it my wish all I did was make it
come true if you're not happy with it I
take it up with our customer support
okay so Alicia fund that hot it wants to
be God she says I wish I was a god
by God of white how about that
crab god oh yeah now how do we make her
into crab God
she's a crab God a crab god she's muddy
or scrape God with river boon or crab
people crab people
well that's about that about does it
that's as much effort as I'm gonna give
that one may be a little glowy effect
look at that Wow
now you know it's a god she wanted to be
a god and so she became crab God
destined to rule the galaxies you're
welcome I'll be paid just PayPal me
thank you
I wish my done with alright sim cookster
wishes her dog was a wizard what was wit
sir tab Oh a beard of course of course
he needs a badass cane ain't a whiz that
without no cane [ __ ] there we go
your dog is a wizard amazing Wow I mean
wolf III yes all right we have time for
one more
we have viola who wish she was a spider
why I don't know the spiders are
terrifying oh god they're so scary my
god
why would you ever want to be a spider
Oh Oh God
oh yeah see oh maybe she likes it she
wanted to be a spy nerd why did they all
have to be so scary god damn it oh god
dance if you want me to do more wishes
for you Bruce leave it like I hope you
enjoyed this video and as always stay
awesome bros this is basically a game
about building furniture that you get
from a care I reach people can't build
her everyone knows everyone so I'm just
gonna go ahead and start here we have a
Buick perk
which doesn't mean she